covet 19 is surging once again
worldwide and here in europe urban
centers are at the forefront of the wave
from marseille to munich paris to prague
the continent cities are rushing to
impose new rules
ranging from prohibitions on parties and
closure of bars
to curfews and travel bans
restrictions on public life still fall
short of last spring's lockdowns
for now as the world waits for a vaccine
can the virus be stopped our title
coronavirus hot spots are europe's
cities
out of control
[Music]
and it is a pleasure to introduce our
guests
starting with martian meyer he works as
a science editor
for the german radio broadcaster
deutschland funk
and he believes despite scientific
progress the pandemic will prevail
therefore we will have to get along with
further restrictions
and it's a pleasure to introduce richard
frieba he works as a science editor for
the berlin daily
de tagespigel and he says we are only at
the beginning of the cold and indoor
season
and there is a real danger of things
getting out of hand in some places
and i'm pleased to welcome our colleague
mira frica she's a science reporter and
editor here at dw
and she's convinced egoism won't
get us through the pandemic
[Music]
so let me ask you uh martin mayer the
the pandemic will prevail as you said in
your opening statement
sounds pretty ominous we have worldwide
nearly 40
million cases now a hundred thousand new
infections per day
here in europe how worried should we be
i think we should be worried i think the
next weeks
will be very challenging for all of us
because what we see is
we had a feeling maybe that the
situation is in control over the summer
unfortunately it's not this pandemic did
not stop we are in the middle of the
second wave the numbers go
up at some places they explode and that
is worrisome
that number i just quoted for europe
means it now accounts for about
one-third of cases worldwide though it
certainly doesn't account for that share
of the global population so what
uh is the reason for this rather dubious
distinction
for europe
i think we're not quite sure at the
moment yeah i think it will take
a lot of time so also um after the
pandemic to analyze what went wrong
where were the turning points for
certain regions
what was the decisive factor i think at
the moment it's still a lot of
guess working but i mean what we can see
is that
europe is generally we have a lot of hot
spots with dense population
that definitely causes problems but i
mean there are other
places in the world where the population
is equally dense and
maybe they're handling it better than
europe so we will have to see
richard your opening statement mentions
the
change of season in summer here in
europe
things almost seemed normal and i think
perhaps a lot of us got
lulled into a sense of false security
was this second wave that we're seeing
an inevitable result of colder weather
or would you say that mistakes were made
i think mistakes were made opportunities
were not taken the way they could have
been taken like you know i remember in
late spring early summer people started
to talk about corona in the past tense
actually like it's
it's disappeared um we had
so much of an urge to get back to our
normal ways
um and um a lot of opportunities were
missed
especially in trying to limit the number
of infections
as we go into the cold season it's kind
of
i mean scary is a big word but it's uh i
i think it's
it's reasonable to call it scary that we
already
now are seeing this surge
in cases we could have done better we
could have
gone into the fall season with much less
infection and with
much better preparation
many people thought that germany was the
poster child
for handling corona and in fact it did
significantly better than many of its
neighbors dealing with the first
wave of infection how are things looking
now
i don't think we've ever been the poster
child to be honest i think we've been
very lucky
especially in the beginning because we
had more time the vibrance was spreading
in other parts of europe so we had more
time to prepare
for our measures and then i'd say the
german government
did a lot of things that they did a good
job in a lot of ways i would say in
general
and especially the germans themselves
they
sticked to the measures now we see we
are tired
i think we all are i personally am as
well i want to go back to normal
it's not possible but that is really
something that
it's very stressful so i don't think
that we in germany should be in any way
proud or prouder than anyone in the rest
of the world because it's a pandemic
the word means we're in this together
let me let's talk a little bit about
that
stress that martin just mentioned he
also mentioned the fact that
having information played a big role in
the spring and helping
germany to respond quickly and
effectively
at this point i think many people are
beginning to feel
overwhelmed by the constant media drum
beat
of information of new findings of
suggestions and recommendations
is there a risk do you think mira that
this can backfire and make people
perhaps less willing to take action and
almost become defeatist i mean we know
very well from neuroscience that
if we bombard people with information
with the same information or with also
shocking information scary information
they will shut down at some point and
not take that information as serious
as we should and we might have a little
bit of that effect at the moment
um i think it is also a huge problem
that um we are sometimes not consistent
enough with
what we expect people to do and
what we recommend and i think that this
inconsistency
can also cause some confusion or this
kind of
people wanting to oh now they come up
with yet another thing oh they come up
with yet another thing
and not trying to listen carefully what
people or
authorities recommend let's take a
deeper
dive on what it is that we're expecting
people to do
we are seeing a plethora not only of new
numbers but also of
new rules so let's take a quick virtual
trip to see how some of europe's
cities are coping and what regulations
they're putting into place
hot spot madrid a partial lockdown has
been imposed
on the spanish capital and surrounding
municipalities
this affects a good four million people
only those who have to go to work or to
a doctor
are allowed to leave madrid is
responsible for around one-third of
coronavirus infections in the country
so the central government feels
justified for issuing the state of
emergency
maximum alert level in paris cafes and
bars are closed
strict hygiene rules have been
introduced in restaurants
alcohol consumption in public spaces is
prohibited
as are large parties the latest measure
is evening curfews
and more restrictions may be coming
berlin is counting on a curfew bars
restaurants and shops must now
shut down between 11 pm and 6 am
no more than 5 people are allowed to
meet at once and parties are considered
to be the prime culprits of a pandemic
i actually wanted to celebrate my 20th
birthday today and i was really looking
forward to it
with the curfew it's really a pity that
you can't live here as freely now
will the future of the pandemic be
decided in big cities
let me pass that question straight on to
richard
will the battle against corona be
decided in cities and if so why
well i mean we we see the
rise in cases now in the cities that
there's a lot of reasons for that
people living closer together but also
the availability of
testing maybe a population that's more
conscious of the
problem so
certainly we're now seeing a lot of the
cases
there but it could spread especially um
because awareness uh in the countryside
sometimes seems to be not as high
so it's a very complex situation and
nobody really knows the answers
that's also true for what measures work
well or
what measures work best during the
lockdowns in
spring and early summer a lot of
measures were taken at the same time so
it's really hard
to distinguish what what worked best
where the school closures
uh decisive were the mask decisive uh
all we know is that everything kind of
worked together there might have been
some of those measures that didn't
contribute
much to it but we will
have no other choice than probably going
back to some of those
things which in
concert were
able to limit the numbers as i said
or as you said in the beginning we are
facing the cold season we had
the big advantage in the spring that
weather
got better people could
under those restrictions go outside more
i mean we are now
only in the middle of october and
it might get worse i want to get all of
you to parse the different measures in a
moment but let's stay with the question
of cities uh just for a second and uh
martin certainly president uh macron of
france
sees cities as decisive yesterday
evening on wednesday he ordered a
nighttime curfew
for paris and eight other french cities
saying this
quote we won't be leaving restaurants
anymore after nine pm and we won't be
partying with our friends
do measures like these and those we saw
in that report
do they make sense do they strike the
right balance would you say
well in the end all these measures
follow one big idea and this idea is
to keep people apart keep social
distancing and not have big gatherings
and of course you can argue what do you
do do you have a curfew for pops for
restaurants
do you do you say that big weddings
aren't allowed anymore
things like that in france the situation
got really worse over the last
weeks or the last days especially and i
think that's why macron did that i think
no politician is happy to step in front
of his people and say like let's close
everything especially in paris where
eating out is such an important thing
so it is a balance we have to have to
discuss but i think this
strict balance we don't need that in
germany right now but we have other
measures as well that
in certain areas the pubs close at 11 i
do think that's a good idea
but i think we have to to to just to add
to that we have to really monitor
how people are reacting to these curfews
you know when they
end up drinking in the streets crowding
up in a different place instead
then we have one nothing here so i think
we really have to see how different
um yeah even cultures react to that
because i think there can be a
difference some people might respond to
that quite well and it might work
and in other countries it might not work
because people have a different
mentality i think we cannot forget about
that
let's talk a little more about that
because your opening statement mentioned
egoism
and the importance that people take
responsibility essentially not only for
themselves but for each other so
at the end of the report we saw that
young man in berlin
who was disappointed at not being able
to celebrate his
birthday how can we reach young people
because it does seem that
young people are increasingly becoming
the
spreader generation the 20 to 30 year
olds i think in particular
what do you think is a way to get them
not to be egoistic
i think we have to make people aware of
the consequences
of their behavior and
i think it is always good to say yeah
you might not be
so severely infected that you need to go
on yeah you know a respiratory
device or that you need like intensive
care help but you have potentially
a lot of people in your
close um surrounding that might as well
have that problem and you might be
responsible
for actually killing a person by
infecting it i mean i think we have to
be that drastic to
to to make that comparison and i think
also we don't we always talk about the
elderly right we want to
oh the elderly we're going to die and
you know oh your grandma might get
infected but i think it's really
important to say
the risk group is not the elderly the
risk
group is also a lot of people with
co-morbidities with asthma for example
with pre-existing conditions exactly
there are a lot of
young people with asthma as well and i
think we've already seen
that some people who have asthma and
contract the virus
and go for kovitt 19 that they come up
come down with really harsh long-term
effects of this sickness richard
one country that we didn't see in our
report uh but that is quite notable is
italy it was at the absolute crust of
the first
wave of covid in europe with disastrous
consequences for the health system many
of our viewers will remember the
pictures
of the italian nurses and doctors
breaking down
now the situation there is looking
better than in many other european
countries
what is italy doing right can we learn
from them i
actually it's very hard to tell you know
i think they uh the experience there
the harsh experience uh was a lesson
uh that they still very much remember
their lesson uh was uh
very decisive for us to take measures in
the
uh in the spring so i really don't know
there is
as i said it's very complex chance might
be involved as well you know
um the structure of the population um
maybe people older people taking better
care of themselves as before or being
taken care better by their families so
it's really
it's really hard to pinpoint one certain
uh
one one particular thing i think martin
both
bavaria's minister president and also
the mayor of berlin who are not
exactly on the same political wavelength
most of the time
both say they're not ruling out that we
may see still more severe restrictions
imposed in germany
including even a lockdown once again
can you really envisage that happening
here particularly given the economic
impact it would have
the chancellor said it must be avoided
at all costs it should be avoided
um for a lot of reasons for economical
reasons for social reasons as well
because we
sometimes tend to forget that a lot of
people were
locked away elderly people in care homes
that's also a big
big effect we i think shouldn't forget
um
i actually don't know i hope it's not
gonna be like we've had in germany like
the situation we've had at the beginning
of this pandemic
but it is not a given fact that it's not
gonna happen
the chances are there that we still or
might face another lockdown
mayor the chancellor has also been
saying that she absolutely wants to keep
schools
open that it's very important not to
sacrifice the educational well-being and
social well-being of children will
germany and will europe be able to do
that going forward do you think what's
the latest finding on the degree to
which schools are spreaders
i think there's not yet very strong
scientific evidence that
schools are the origin of
big infection clusters i think that we
can
say that it looks like they are not
reason number one
which then again is a reason to keep
them open especially for smaller
children
i think it is totally possible to find a
good balance um teaching some children
in school
having a little bit of homeschooling for
others have some kind of maybe
a shift system where they come in every
second day or where the
the the younger ones go to class where
the older ones rather stay at home
i think it's absolutely possible to keep
schools open
with a reasonable hygiene concept
and another um another point
of where there's perhaps the lesson to
be learned from how
things were dealt with in the first wave
of the virus
it was every country for itself at that
time
borders were closed national authorities
scrambled to get hold of masks and
equipment
sometimes at the expense of others who
needed them more
since then there have been a lot of vows
to not have that repeat itself
what do you think will we see better
coordination and cooperation
amongst different countries in europe
and also amongst
different cities than we did during the
first wave and i'm thinking especially
about the sharing of hospital capacity
for example
i mean again experience is a plus on
this
side i mean we've
started doing this kind of coordination
in the spring
i think it's going to work better but it
also
is also going to depend on the uh on the
extent
of this on the severity of the of the
pandemic so it
things may get out of hand uh just
because you know
medical personnel in large numbers will
not be able to cope anymore they've
they've gone through it before so um
i think coordination is key but
it's it's hard really to predict how
much you can count on it
speaking of cooperation let's take a
quick
look at the state of vaccine research it
is preceding a pace
yet even under the best case scenario
europe cities will have to manage
the virus for some time to come here's a
closer look at the timeline for one
project based here in germany
an ad by biontech the mains-based
biotechnology firm
could soon become the first german
company to produce its genetically
engineered vaccine
by the millions with its u.s partner
pfizer
that's because buy-in tech is currently
in the third critical phase of vaccine
testing
with 37 000 volunteer test subjects and
an accelerated eu approval process is
already underway at the moment
research is moving at an incredible
speed currently
the ministry for research expects that
large portions of the population
will be able to be vaccinated by the
middle of next year
two other german pharmaceutical
manufacturers are competing with buy-in
tech
and not only that the world health
organization lists 180 active vaccine
programs
of which at least eight are in the third
phase of testing
we see this less as a race against each
other and more is one to get the
pandemic under control there will be
several rounds of approval
but competition has been raging about
when each country will receive the
vaccine
mayor what do you think which country or
which company will win the competition
and your opening statement mentioned
eager ways
egoism so let me ask you how cut throat
you think that this vaccine competition
is likely to become
um i'm going to be honest and say i
really really hope
it's not going to be cathro's situation
that we we will encounter
i really hope that everyone will see
that it makes absolutely no sense in
this pandemic that we have to work
together
that we have to
really think about what is best for
everyone no matter which country they
are living
i do think that pfizer and biontech
is a good candidate to maybe bring one
of the first vaccines in europe onto the
market
but we will see something can always
happen in
in a trial phase martine we heard a
pretty optimistic prognosis there from
the german research minister that large
segments of the population here
could be vaccinated by the middle of
next year would you share that optimism
no i wouldn't i'm not that sure
i'm not so sure um i think in the end
we'll have more than one vaccine that
will come to an end at the moment
the who says about more than a dozen are
in the clinical
third phase of the important phase of of
the testing
but still then this um this vaccine has
to be produced and
um then we have to think we have to make
a call who is more important to get the
vaccine first
elderly maybe people who work in
hospitals i'd say
but i'm not that sure as our minister is
that this will be
for everyone or almost everyone richard
martin and our report both mentioned the
third phase that is usually seen as
pretty far along
in the testing process but the u.s
company
johnson and johnson just interrupted
phase three
trials because a participant
unexpectedly
became ill now does that mean that phase
three
is perhaps less decisive and more
fragile than
many people have led us to believe
well i mean there's it's always going
going to be the situation
in phase three something will happen uh
the the problem with
uh the current situation is that we have
speeded up
things so much so there will also be
trade-offs and the trade-offs will be
maybe vaccines that are less effective
than they could have been if we
had uh three years to development um
another trade-off might be when even
larger groups of
people get an a vaccine after it's been
approved
that they met there might be serious
problems with it so
those trade-offs are going to be there
the the to look at a possible vaccine or
a group of vaccines as as the big
solution
uh to the whole crisis is um a little
bit short-sighted i would think
then let me come back to our title for
one very quick
final round to all of you and it's this
in view of that fact in view of the fact
that we're clearly going to be
this virus is going to be with us for a
number of months to come
what for you is the most crucial thing
you can we can do to get it
under control coming back to our title
mira
most crucial measure i think every one
of us
should be aware that they make a
difference every single one of us makes
a difference
we have to be proactive not reactive
and i would always say just wear your
mask
i would totally agree and i would just
add that i think we all have to ask
ourselves these days do we really need
to travel now
is that really the most important thing
at the moment or should we
sometimes just limit ourselves as
annoying it is as stressful it is but i
think it's the only thing we can do
a big discussion right now here in
germany with people looking to go on
fall break and
using corona testing capacity to try to
get
the means to do so um richard i
completely agree with
both of you i think we have to embrace
the situation with all
its uh insecurities and also
the fact that we can make a difference
um we can be solidarity with other
people
uh by just acting responsively
responsibly uh wearing masks keeping
distance
uh not overdoing uh parties
things like that the robert koch
institute germany's leading
essentially center for disease control
says that a mass
could be as important as a vaccine if
not more so would you agree with that
i think the mask is what we have now and
it's
it's proven to be very effective so
let's uh
stick with the mask for them thank you
very much thanks to
all of you for being with us and thanks
to you for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you